joining us on the line is amy padkov
she's an american writer blogger
professor of philosophy and the law and
the chief policy officer of social media
platform parlor for those who have not
been watching the news over the weekend
the biggest story of the weekend
was not all the social media bannings of
trump or the
various goings-on involving trump's
companies the biggest
development of the weekend was the
complete deep platforming of parlor
which was
supposed to be the conservative
alternative to twitter amy thanks so
much for joining the show
thanks for inviting me on so why don't
we start with the actual
timeline of events here uh what what
drove
this and when were you guys notified
that you were going to be not just
kicked off of the
apple app store uh or kicked off a
google but also have your
complete access to the internet taken
away by having your server access
revoked by amazon
yeah so the first that we heard of this
was about noon pacific time
on friday and that was the notification
from the
apple app store that we needed to
make certain changes and you know
remove certain content from the platform
and tell them about our plan for dealing
with this content within 24 hours
otherwise be
taken down and then about an hour and a
half later is when we got the
notification
from amazon similarly
phrased so what content did they
actually want
taken down so there are obviously you
know things put up by people like
lynn wood that were calling for violence
against the vice president what are the
actual
policy standards that parlor had put in
place to begin with and then what were
the changes that were asked for by these
companies
sure so we all have the same standard
right we all have the same goal
because incitement of violence that is
not free speech
and of course we are a free speech
platform but that is not
protected by the first amendment and so
we were all on the same page with
respect to the goal
but as you know this content this
inciting content has been
everywhere on the internet in massive
quantities
and so where we were at odds is with
respect to
the expectations that you would have of
a platform
in this particular time and then also
the strategies by which we all should be
wanting to
you know filter or remove this content
right so on parlor
we have resisted using artificial
intelligence any sort of
algorithm that automatically scans all
content on the platform because of our
focus on privacy you know i've been a
big
advocate for privacy for a long time and
it was one of the
affinities that i had and why i joined a
parlor
and we believe at parlor that orwell's
1984 is a dystopian novel it's not an
instruction manual right
and the crucial decision that everybody
has to make right now
is do we think the standard of care for
any platform on the internet
is that everybody is going to have each
piece of content
scanned 24 7 all the time
by an algorithm which basically means no
privacy at
all and we were resisting that now
i think i don't know how about you ben
but i was somewhat surprised at the way
that things went
this last week in washington dc
and i don't know that people anticipated
that it was going to
play out exactly how it did
this is an unusual circumstance there is
a ton of this content
it's on all of the platforms out there
and we feel like we have been singled
out
a lot of course because we have the
reputation of being the conservative
platform
although really you know we're
nonpartisan but the fact that we're
nonpartisan and we're focused on freedom
of expression
has attracted a lot of conservatives to
parlor so
that you know all of those things have
worked together suddenly
friday afternoon we get dumped on and
told that we have to make significant
changes
lightning quick otherwise be completely
de-platformed
and they did not work with us we you
know we have been scrambling all weekend
doing putting things in place trying to
deal with this content
but they have not been cooperative and
they took us down so amy realistically
speaking i mean if there is no ai being
used to sort of scan all of the various
content
i suppose that basically leaves it to
individual employees to go through all
of these posts but as you mentioned
parlor is a very large company at this
point it's got hundreds of thousands of
users
uh so how much of the content can
actually even be seen by human beings
who work for parlor in order to take it
down if it does if it did for example
inside violence
well of course we don't depend on only
parlor employees
we have the ability of any person on
parlor
to report that content and of course we
had a lot of it reported to
the community jury and then get
processed through that and then taken
down
so the question is do you want to have a
process like that which is really more
like
the process that you would have on a
public square
in the real world which is that if
somebody sees
evidence of a crime that they report it
to the authorities and then it's dealt
with
appropriately that is the sort of system
that we had had in place on parlor and
that was what we were doing
you might say that extraordinary
circumstances like the events of the
last week
require ratcheting up at least for a
period of time and so we were over the
weekend discussing
ways to do that but we were not
shown any cooperation from amazon
yesterday for example when we were in
those discussions they just shut it off
in the middle of the night we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first
let us talk about protecting your online
safety and security by using express vpn
expressvpn it's an app for your computer
and phone it secures and encrypts your
data
so you have peace of mind every time you
go online expressvpn will hide your ip
address
lets you control where you want sites to
think you are located and the app
connects with just one click it's really
really fast so i'm going to show you how
this thing works so here i go i'm
scrolling over on my phone to the
expressvpn app i just opened
it up right now it says not connected
like this boink
and now there it is it's going and it's
connected i am now protected i can
search for anything i want online
without having to worry about my vpn
being exposed so i heard earlier this
week that demi lovato
was headed over to the studio to cut a
song to save democracy she's going to
save democracy guys because it's really
in trouble
so i just wanted to get an update so
let's see did demi
lovato save democracy
this week yeah unfortunately the answer
is is no
well find out how you can get three
months of expressive vpn for free by
visiting expressvpn.com
shapiro or clicking the link in the
description box below when
as you mentioned you know your your
platform is being
singled out i mean twitter was a
cesspool in 2016. i mean so much so that
i was the single largest recipient of
death threats on twitter
i believe in in 2016. uh obviously the
same holds true
for facebook where people were using
facebook to organize black lives matter
protests in the middle of the summer
many of which burned into actual violent
conflagrations
and yet there was no talk at any point
of anybody deplatforming the entire app
of getting rid of twitter getting rid of
facebook removing
their their web services access maybe
you can explain
the difference for folks between even
what apple
and google did here and what amazon did
because what amazon did
is to me significantly more dangerous
even than what apple and google did i
mean it's bad enough to be removed from
the app store which is
a form of of repression but
if not legal repression then certainly
cultural repression but to to have
what is supposed to be uh basically a
server farm declared that you can no
longer use their services sounds more
akin to a credit card company saying you
can't use your credit card to subscribe
to daily wire or to buy a subscription
and national review right no it's
definitely similar to that because
the number of companies that have the
ability to provide server on that
scale are few and so
being you know told on a very short
notice
that it's going to be withdrawn and
we're supposed to scramble and be able
to get back online that quickly or tran
you know migrate over to other servers
is very unrealistic and i'll tell you i
got an
email from the amazon trust and safety
team as they call it
earlier in the week it was on wednesday
last week
and they forwarded a complaint a generic
complaint about
inciting and violent content on parlor
but there was no specific link to any
particular piece of content just a
general
complaint and so i wrote them back and i
said i don't see any
link to specific content here but yes of
course this content is everywhere right
now
and if you want to discuss the way in
which we've been handling it
i would love to get on a call and talk
about it with you thursday
i get a response from amazon and they
say
this was for your information only we
consider this matter resolved
friday afternoon we get the big notice
from amazon that we're in imminent
danger of being taken down
and that does not seem right of course i
like everybody else
who was in a similar position on the
other platforms of course we're a
smaller startup and all of us are
struggling
but you know just imagine the vast
amount of this content
and that you're doing your best to keep
up with it given the resources that you
have
i i don't think that this is a fair
standard to hold a startup and a
competitor who was just
trying to have fidelity to principles
and do this right
i don't think we were treated fairly at
all so amy you for a long time known me
for for many years and you've been a
libertarian for a very long time
uh and the the sort of libertarian take
on this sort of stuff typically is
well you know the free market works out
the free market's gonna work that was
the pitch behind parlor in the first
place as people kept saying okay well
twitter is banning people we don't like
how they're handling their business
they're allowing
chinese propaganda to go out and iranian
threats to destroy israel to go out
uh but they're very angry at trump and
they'll ban trump so we need an
alternative then
you guys create the alternative and then
they say okay well you know what we
actually don't like that we're gonna
we're gonna go after that um yeah it
starts to make one
question whether you know we are what we
are actually actually seeing here is
essentially monopolistic collusion
because as i've noted on
on twitter and on the show when you look
at web services particularly
amazon runs something like 50 of all of
the cloud-based
web hosting on planet earth uh microsoft
handles something like 16
google's handle google handles four
percent and then it's all
alibaba and a bunch of kind of minor
players so when you guys are looking to
to go back
online here have you been able to take
it are any of these other places
offering you the ability to use their
servers or is micro
microsoft google are they all holding
the same standard and if so what are you
guys going to do about your your server
problem here
yeah obviously what we're doing is we're
scrambling to replace and the other
thing is there's been this
sort of uh crowd think follow the crowd
so once you've had amazon and
apple making their very public
announcements about this
uh i almost see it's a little bit of
virtue signaling
right then other service providers
have cut off their service with various
consequences as well
so we are currently scrambling to
replace
or you know grow for ourselves all the
various services that we were being
provided that got cut off suddenly
because of this sudden you know notice
that we got on friday
and we're going to build back up again
and and get online as quickly as
possible but it is not
easy because like you say i mean i
didn't realize that was the percentage
of amazon but as i understand you know
they provide services for twitter
our competitor and uh you know it it is
a very cornered market there's one thing
to say okay there's a free market
and that you know they have the right of
course
to not provide service the way in which
they discontinued service
i think is something that people should
look at and decide how much business you
want to do with amazon
i'm uh wondering you know how well my
defense of jeff bezos to tucker a couple
years ago
years ago actually ages at this point
right
um so we can make these judgment calls
about the ethics and the way that
they're doing the business and and
in you know the fact that this has
evolved into this cancel culture
out there i am being of course viciously
attacked because i have somehow
been single-handedly responsible for the
planning and coordination of the events
of january 6th and i think the whole
purpose
and the spirit of section 230 is that
there is
such a thing as a platform where you
provide a service and the people who
post the content
on the service are the ones responsible
for it
right i mean that's you you agree with
that
that that it is properly that would be
something that you would do
and it would comport with the
spirit of the internet i mean we have
tim berners-lee the creator of the world
wide web
who his whole point was to give
everybody a voice and not to have
censorship out there on the internet
and it seems increasingly that everybody
wants the standard to be orwell's 1984
where every piece of content you put out
there is scanned
by an algorithm 24 7 all the time
and i really want to ask our detractors
out there and the ones who are attacking
it
is this really what you want because
parlor what you know again reputation
for conservative platform or not
we were a non-partisan see i'm saying
were this is so sad
we are still fighting and um this is a
very
hard morning so excuse me um we're a
non-partisan
public square not and completely
nonpartisan in the enforcement of all
policies and everything else
and we just wanted to provide the
maximum amount of freedom of expression
consistent with the law and
do so in a way that respects privacy for
individuals and also provides good
monetization opportunities so
sorry getting calls i'm people uh
from the press calling a lot right now
no i mean amy i want to ask you
one of the things that has happened here
is that uh section 230
here was originally designed in order to
allow people to moderate comments the
baseline
thesis was that if you were an open
source if you if you were a comment
section or if you were
uh just a thread that the the provider
of that platform was not responsible for
the commentary that was on the platform
that
there was a stark division between the
phone line and the person speaking on
the phone line
and section 230 was designed to allow
people to curate their comments that
presumably the comment section could be
better
it seems like we have now completely
reversed the polarity we're the only
people
who are now free of legal liability are
the ones who are moderating whereas if
you don't moderate then you are
somehow hit with the liability in a
different way which is completely the
reverse of what it used to be
no exactly and so i believe that
the sort of changes that mark zuckerberg
and other competitors have been pushing
for and lobbying for in congress to
section 230 where they say that they're
open to
new and improved regulations i think
what they want to do
is mandate moderation standards
that conform to their philosophy of
community guidelines
and that would take away freedom of
expression we don't have that yet that's
what they're lobbying for
but in effect that was what was imposed
in the marketplace this last weekend on
parlor
we're being told that you should adopt
the moderation
policies of the established players in
this market
otherwise we're not going to give you
our services
and today in effect that means it's
going to be very hard for you to survive
like i said we are determined to make
this happen but we have an uphill battle
and we have been taken offline of course
you know we were number one in the app
store
right all right well amy pickoff she is
the
chief policy officer uh officer of
parlor uh we'll check in with you again
appreciate your time and uh and good
luck with all this
we'll be out there uh supporting the
right of other apps to start that are
not actually twitter
appreciated amy thank you ben i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show if you did go ahead and hit the
subscribe button so you stay up to date
on all of our future content